no solo está buscando apoyo en occidente
sino también además en la liga árabe
donde participó para qué le sirve en
estos encuentros
Hola primero Buenas tardes Muchas
gracias por la invitación Bueno es muy
simple lo que pasa es que decirles que
no solo puede ganar la guerra con el
apoyo de occidente con las armas o con
apoyo económico necesita que las
sanciones contra Rusia efectivamente
funcionan y el problema es que si los
demás actores del sistema internacional
como Oriente medio China India y otros
actores no excluyen O finalmente o no
sancionan a Rusia o no reducen su
relación económica con Rusia pues la
invasión seguirá teniendo los recursos
necesarios para seguir existiendo así
que efectivamente La idea es que no solo
consolidar el apoyo del mundo occidental
a través de armas y efectivamente un
compromiso político sino sobre todo
empezar a cambiar la postura de los
demás actores que tal como ya se dijo
muy bien han asumido una posición mucho
más neutral y que no han excluido
completamente a Rusia del escenario
internacional y como usted dice estos
países que no han sido alia directos de
Ucrania son claves pero que tanta
recepción tuvo el presidente de esquí
por parte de Naciones por ejemplo como
India Arabia Saudita y Brasil
es complicado la verdad es que no
digamos que no esperaban compromiso 100%
digamos Claro pero igual en la situación
tampoco ha cambiado mucho porque lo que
lo que pide es que efectivamente estos
países cambian radicalmente su postura y
es muy difícil el caso de Saudita es muy
interesante porque ahora ves ahorita por
ejemplo digamos no está directamente
apoyando a Rusia pero sus intereses
económicos asociados con la estabilidad
de los precios del petróleo por ejemplo
han beneficiado mucho a Rusia con el
marco de la OPEP por ejemplo la Arabia
Saudita solicitó a reducir la producción
para mantener el precio alto eso por
supuestamente ayuda a Rusia y en ese
contexto digamos el apoyo no es
completamente directo de rabia Saudita
pero si hay un apoyo que es muy difícil
romper para Ucrania en el caso de Brasil
es muy diferente porque Brasil Busca un
liderazgo internacional nuevo renovado
con por supuesto en el marco de los
priques y Rusia es uno de los miembros
de ese grupo lo que significa que
digamos una oposición directa de de
Brasil implicaría cuestionar el mismo la
misma organización Así que también es
muy muy difícil y finalmente el caso de
India Pues que se ha vuelto un nuevo
Aliado y nuevo socio económico ruso que
sea beneficiado mucho de los precios de
energía que Rusia que Rusia está
produciendo que pues Rusia le está
vendiendo ahora India pero es más
baratos lo que también significa que
digamos es difícil romper ese compromiso
y esos acuerdos una de las ideas que más
está promoviendo es la coalición de los
casas con la que busca que occidente de
su brazo a torcer y envíe por fin
aviones de combate a Ucrania que tanto
logró al respecto
digamos hay un compromisos de Estados
Unidos para permitir que otros estados
lo hagan Estados Unidos no lo va a hacer
directamente al parecer pero no va a
impedir que algunos otros actores decían
hacerlo pero también es una decisión
política muy sensible dado que estamos
hablando de nuevas armas que podrían
incluso llegar a atacar directamente a
Rusia
o territorio ruso lo que por supuesto de
nuevo lo hace muy difícil de aprobar o
lo que lo hace muy difícil de
materializar Así que sí digamos hay un
avance muy significativo Y es que
Estados Unidos no se va a poner pero
ahora el siguiente paso es que
efectivamente algunos países realmente
estén completamente dispuestos a correr
ese riesgo de alguna forma y aumentar la
atención no en Rusia Ucrania porque pues
ya no se puede pero sí aumentar la
tensión entre los países que entreguen
en sus casas y Rusia y de nuevo es
también una decisión política que es muy
difícil de justificar a nivel de digamos
discurso político interno para los
países de